hey 42 here a quick warning before we
begin this is a boring video no
seriously it's all about boring but
before we look downwards let's take a
detour up towards space Sputnik 1 was
the first artificial satellites who ever
successfully make it into orbit and it's
launched by the Soviets in 1957 was one
of the most significant achievements in
the early space race on the one hand the
space race was about Cold War rivals the
US and the Soviet Union engaging in a
bit of good old showing off in front of
the rest of the world a classic case of
my rock is bigger than your rocket but
it was also seen as a vital to national
security respond it's launched causing
the bigwigs in Washington to start
panicking that they'd fallen behind the
Soviets in technological prowess but we
all know how the story went from there
just over 10 years later in 1969 the US
came out on top when the Apollo 11 crew
made the 240,000 mile journey to our
nearest neighbor and Neil Armstrong
became the first man to walk on the moon
oh yeah and he botched arguably the most
famous line in all of human history in
the process it's one step for a man Neil
Howe well maybe next time the space race
captured the attention of the world was
some 600 million people watching the
landing live on television but whilst
20% of mankind had their attention
trained on the heavens there was another
kind of race taking place this one
heading in exactly the opposite
action because whilst the US and the
USSR weren't busy strapping their
citizens to rockets and blessing them
into space getting involved in proxy
wars or testing ever more cataclysmic
nuclear weapons they were of all things
preoccupied with attempting to find out
who could take the deepest hole now that
might sound like more the kind of
behavior befitting to board kids on the
beach rather than two of the world's
biggest superpowers but I can assure you
it's true the ultimate aim apart from
yet another round of metaphorical dick
measuring was to become the first nation
in history to drill down through the
earth top layer the crust and into the
mantle below this raised to the center
of the earth is much less famous than
the space race astronauts cosmonauts and
the endless reaches of space are just
that much cooler than very deep holes
and a bunch of rocks I guess and Bruce
Willis wouldn't come along to make
drilling sexy again until 1998 when
Armageddon was released but in many ways
the quest to reach the Earth's mantle
was more of a journey into the unknown
than the one taken by Neil and the gang
on Apollo 11
because believe it or not whilst
Humanity was busy pushing back the
boundaries of space and developing ever
more advanced technology we still were
surprisingly ignorant as to what was
going on down here on earth right
beneath our feet it wouldn't be until
almost 10 years after Sputnik Warren
made it into orbits that's the theory of
plate tectonics would finally be agreed
upon for example this unifying theory
was absolutely vital to our
understanding of the geological
processes that shaped the earth without
it scientists were divided as to what
exactly caused earthquakes and volcanoes
and though they recognize how the
coastlines of South America and Africa
were a suspiciously snug fit nobody was
quite sure what mechanism could have
split them apart and while scientists
had come up with some ingenious ways to
better understand the calm
of the earth despite only ever having
scratched its surface they were fully
aware that without hard evidence their
theories were just that theories the US
and USSR took two very different
approaches to the challenge of drilling
down into the mantle the Soviets found
the nice barren stretch of land on the
Kola Peninsula to start digging whilst
the Americans decided to take a crafty
shortcut by drilling offshore where the
Earth's crust is significantly thinner
around five to six kilometers deep
versus 30 to 40 beneath the continents
the u.s. quest to reach the mantle was
named project mo Hall after Croatian
seismologist and Ouija maharaja vic who
discovered the boundary between the
crust and the mantle in 1909 through
clever observation of seismic waves the
project began in 1960 of guadalupe of
mexico amid swirling rumors of a similar
project being undertaken by the soviets
remember this was just three years after
the USSR had got him one over on their
arch-rivals with the launch of Sputnik 1
and the Americans were nervous of being
second-best
once again project mogul was led by the
curiously named miscellaneous society an
eccentric bunch of rather brilliant
scientists known for awarding their
members a genuine stuffed albatross as
an award for significant achievements
their motto was illegitimate non
carborundum a mock Latin aphorism which
roughly translates as don't let the
bastards grind you down yes it was these
guys the Americans chose to go up
against the might of the USSR picture
Rocky Balboa versus Ivan Drago in rocky
4 only replaced rocky with a quaint old
professor wearing a monocle and carrying
a stuffed albatross on the one arm
spoiler alert professor Balboa is going
to get seven shades of [ __ ] kicked out
of him in this one kids at least he
could use his albatross to block punches
instead of his face although the
Americans have cleverly sidestepped the
need to drill through the first 25
kilometers or so of crust by starting on
the ocean floor they did have one
problem deepwater ocean drilling
hadn't been invented yet
and unsurprisingly drilling of every
deep hole in the ocean floor whilst
bobbing around in a constantly moving
ship isn't exactly a walk in the park
but if there's one thing oddball
academics are good at its overcoming
complex technical challenges
thanks to their invention of dynamic
positioning computer controlled system
not automatically maintains a ship's
position using a series of
interconnected frosters the project got
off to a great start
led by the multi-talented Willard Bascom
it was an engineer adventurer scientists
writer photographer painter miner
cinematographer and archaeologist
phase 1 testing resulted in the first
successful untethered deepwater drilling
ever completed give that man an
albatross maybe just a small one though
because of the five holes drilled the
deepest was only 183 metres but the
important thing was they'd proven it was
possible oh and I forgot to mention to
make this strange project that little
bit stranger legendary author John
Steinbeck just happened to be along for
the ride taking some time off between
writing the winter of our discontent and
winning himself a Nobel Prize for
Literature John an amateur oceanographer
in his spare time was on board
reporting on the project for a special
feature in Life Magazine despite its
early success things soon took a turn
for the worse her project Mohall you'd
have thought that someone might have
picked up on this a little sooner but it
turns out drilling down to the mantle is
a pricey business and funding was caught
not long after the completion of phase 1
when the guys holding the purse strings
heard just how much phase 2 is going to
cost this came along with the usual
helping of political scheming academic
infighting in general bickerings offered
by all great projects meaning phase 2
never got off the ground or for that
matter under it
yes project Mohall eventually went the
way of Lennie in Of Mice and Men and was
sadly terminated its profile having
being raised by Steinbeck's popular
report project mal halt became something
of a national joke in the following
months with Newsweek magazine dubbing
the failed expedition project no hull
very good the russians meanwhile took a
little while longer to get their act
together despite those rumours over in
the US around the time mole hole was
being set up
it wasn't until 1970 that the soviet
project actually got going it was worth
the wait the soviet borehole was just
nine inches thick but don't believe the
rumors girth isn't everything because
those soviets they went deep real deep
just how deep i hear you ask
put it this way if i was to ask you what
the deepest point on earth is there's a
decent chance you'd say the Mariana
Trench the deepest part of the Pacific
Ocean if you're a real smartass you
might even go with the challenger deep
the very deepest part of the Mariana
Trench which is a dizzying ten thousand
nine hundred meters down but as I'm sure
you've guessed by now you'd be wrong on
both counts because the deepest known
place on earth to this day lies at the
bottom of a hole dug by the Russians in
order to get one over on the Americans
during the Cold War known as the Kola
super-deep borehole presumably named by
an imagination elite challenged Soviet
due to its location on the Kola
Peninsula and the fact that it is like
super deep man this particular hole goes
down a frankly ridiculous 12.2
kilometers to make a feeble attempt at
putting that number into some kind of
context the Kola super-deep borehole is
deeper than Mount Everest is tall it's
deeper even in the cruising altitude of
a Boeing 747 and if you were to somehow
fall into it for which you would need to
have one hell of a narrow waistline
would take you around for four minutes
our free fall before you hit the bottom
very very hard as an interesting aside
in his book do colors exist
mathematicians safe standard Cottrell
calculated how long it would take to
fall all the way through the earth if
such a thing were possible for a very
long tube in a vacuum
his conclusion 42 minutes despite the
incredible depth the Soviets reached
they didn't get anywhere near the mantle
as intended making it only about 30
percent of the way through at a certain
depth the temperatures had begun to
increase much more sharply than had been
predicted up to about a hundred and
eighty degrees at the bottom of the ball
it was too much for their equipment to
handle and they were forced to call it a
day drilling ceased in 1990 and the site
was abandoned entirely but many of the
buildings now derelict can still be
found there today on the super-deep
borehole itself it's just sitting there
it's covered by a fairly hefty looking
methyl lid admittedly but below that lid
is a 12 kilometre drop all the way down
adventure tourists are known to visit
the site regularly now maybe it's just
me
that's something kind of creepy about to
hole this deep and perhaps that's why
rumors have circulated over the years
that the Soviet scientists like a bunch
of irresponsible Dwarfs from
middle-earth delved too greedily and too
deep but instead of pissing off a Balrog
these scientists are said to have
unexpectedly broken through into a
colossal cavern curious they then
lowered a heat-resistant microphone
inside to see just what was going on
down there when they came to play about
the tape on the surface they heard the
screams of the damned pass right instead
of finding the mantle the Soviets are
said to have drilled straight down
through the ceiling of hell
I bet Satan was pissed when he found out
is notoriously difficult to find a good
roofer twelve point twelve kilometers
below the surface of the earth
okay so this conspiracy theory is
obviously utter [ __ ] but that didn't
stop several news outlets from reporting
this story at the time seriously
Trinity Broadcasting Network the largest
Christian television network in the
world
actually ran the story in 1989 titling
it scientists discover hell what the
scientists did discover wasn't quite as
exciting as the fiery Inferno of the
underworld but we're still quite
important scientifically they found
liquid water much further down than had
previously been fought possible as well
as microscopic plankton fossils 6.8
kilometers below the surface but of
course the most important discovery was
that yes the Soviets could indeed dig a
deeper hole than the Americans and
therefore most likely did have larger
penises so whilst the u.s. may have won
the space race
it was the Soviets you got furthest in
the race to the center of the earth
though neither side ever did manage to
cross the finish line thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video then
please consider supporting me on patreon
because it really helped me to continue
to make them all so you can get your
hands on a first edition signed copy of
my new book stick if liking it by
heading on over to unbound publishing
you'll find a link in the description
I'm pre-ordering your copy today thank
you